[Music]
they
communicate
the message
transform
transform your community
environment
transform
the status quo
but most importantly they convey the
distinct characteristics of a mechanical
object
and a human being
that
feels
endowed with faculty
endowed with free will
in march 2021 the brain scientist
inventor and national security advisor
newton howard erected two transformer
statues bumblebee and optimus prime
outside his home in washington dc's
georgetown neighborhood
his neighbors were furious
it was intriguing how was an abundance
of real issues out there in the world
two sculptures were at the center of
debate by such high intellectual and
high-powered people
they complained to the dc's department
of consumer and regulatory affairs and
the federally funded old georgetown
board which oversees the historic
district he was fined twenty thousand
dollars and ordered to take down the
statues
this is my property
i'm putting something on it that's one
of the unequal rights you can't just
take it you can't you can't just
come and yank it because you feel like
it
howard decided to fight the order after
11 years in the intelligence community
including as an analyst for the cia
dictating to him what he was allowed to
put on his own property he says was a
violation of the principles he had
dedicated his career to upholding i
would fight it all the way to whatever
highest court
it's a symbolism for freedom of speech
it represents one's ability to freedom
of expression and to just simply take
them down would be to
give away that right
so why did howard put transformers
outside his home
he's not really a toy lover or a fan of
the animated movies or tv shows
he's trying to convey to the world a
philosophical idea about the nature of
free will and the capacity of humans to
remake the world around them i wanted
them to carry that message of
transforming and accepting and changing
things
howard immigrated to the us from france
when he was 11. when i came to the state
i went into a talent show where you
built technological objects and kind of
show and tell
but on a larger scale and i had built a
hydrogen power cell back then and then
kept on building things he invented a
computational system to predict car
malfunctions
after college he joined the army as an
intelligence officer and ended up in the
cia's venture arm which invests in new
technologies during one mission howard
had an experience that changed his life
in one of the exploratory events that i
participated in i
was in a transport that had a
received an ied or some kind of
explosive device that
injured me in the prefrontal areas of my
brain
i'm good now
but it influenced my direction of travel
if you will in life
it's twofold one fold that affects your
physical abilities
and other fold where it takes you to the
darkest corners of your brain
places where you don't want to go
and
when you go there you need to have
the power to actually come back into the
light part of your brain into the
positive side
howard says that he came out of this
experience with the conviction that
humans have enormous power to shape
their own destinies it shifted my
interest
there's an abundance of enemies and
anomalies in the environment that we
live in that's what i meant by seeking
to transform these negative elements in
the environment and bring them down
before they bring us down
when the us withdrew from afghanistan in
august of 2021 leaving behind many of
the men and women who had worked with
the american military howard joined the
private evacuation effort he also signed
on to foster five kids waiting to be
reunited with their parents they're full
of life full of joy
they
have no
awareness or cognizant of the
evil that
surrounded them in afghanistan
war and
conflict is just one of those enemies we
have other things like diseases and
mental disorders and
brain traumas and
neurodegenerative disorders and
slew of other things that requires a
battle also
and that battle
happens at home
after his incident howard decided to
refocus his career on using technology
to transform the experiences of people
suffering from neodegenerative illnesses
in his lab at georgetown university he's
working on a brain implant that would
help treat alzeimer and parkinson's a
device
that i refer to as the kiwi
it's a very small
chip about the size of a grain of rice
and it is used to place into the areas
that have the damage in the brain
bringing about corrections and operating
almost as a micro brain
inside that atrophy zone or the areas
that we have
you know brain that died neurons have
died and what not
it interfaces through connectivity to a
unique material
that these neurons made out of it's
called carbon nanotubes and
modulate electrical and optical or light
if you will in that zone to bring it
back to life
to date we were able to produce some of
those
prototypes
and hopefully very soon we'll be able to
get them to market
howard fears that the fda might delay
the arrival of these implants to market
if the fda and other
regulatory bodies are involved in these
things understood what it needs to
happen to move it faster then it's a
matter of a year two years if there are
delays in understanding of the
technology by the regulators and they
need more definitions and more
understanding then it could take longer
there's an enormous expense and cost
barriers should be simple but i don't
understand their budget constraints and
other things there could be a good
reason why they do things the way they
do
generally bureaucracy
gets under my skin because bitter cracks
tend to granulate a problem or fragment
a problem into multiple problems
and then add on each one of these
problems a human to control it
and then get this whole chaos
to supposedly support a greater good
which is making sure that things are
done right when in fact most of the time
things are done right
but
in
practicalities this is just slowing it
down
in his fight with local planning
agencies over the transformers howard
has prevailed for now he hired a
consulting firm which argued that the
statues constitute works of fine art
conveying the concept of transformation
from some more earthly object into their
hero mode i.e from car truck plane into
action
the old georgetown board agreed to let
him keep the statues on the condition
that he renew his permit every six
months
we're all transformers
we're all about transforming things
transforming is in essence of human
nature how we become in harmony with our
environment
[Music]
you